[Musique]
étranger
rendez-
le le plus heureux dont vous puissiez vous souvenir
on a l'impression qu'aucun temps ne s'est écoulé et que
beaucoup de temps s'est
écoulé c'était le moment idéal pour s'asseoir avec
tout le monde et se remémorer
[Musique]
la chose qui m'a le plus effrayé
était  l'implication que la chose la plus
significative de notre vie a été faite
et qu'il y a quelque chose de si joyeux à
voir tout le monde
et à être comme s'il n'y en avait pas, bien que l'un des
moments forts de ma part ait été quand j'ai dû
faire semblant d'être Hermione prétendant
être une meilleure blague  Je n'aime pas qu'on me fasse
attendre j'ai encore les dents en
fait je vais les mettre si tu veux ma
sœur a des enfants qui ont eu environ
10 11 12 ans et j'ai dit Martha je ne sais pas
pour ce Voldemort quoi  on vous
demandera de jouer Voldemort
[Applaudissements]
Je ne serais pas la personne que je suis sans tant
de gens ici,
c'est une chose très écrasante parce que
je t'ai vu grandir et j'ai
vu toutes les étapes de ma vie
quand les choses deviennent
un lien fort, cela arrivera toujours
[Musique]
nous sommes une famille et nous ferons toujours partie
de la vie de l'autre
[Musique]